how can we make a really long sequence  for an audience and have them experience  what it's like holding your breath for  that period of time you have to over  train for a sequence we are doing up to  six and a half minute breath holds Let's  Not freak people out too much I hadn't  done any free diving before and I hadn't  held my breath for long periods of time  and I have to say physically  it was it was without a doubt the most  challenging aspect of the film  underwater photography is  extraordinarily difficult and time  consuming it's dangerous it's slow it's  very exhausting and he's doing it simply  because he loves the idea that when this  is eventually put into the movie The  Audience will be holding their breath  because he's holding his